how serious was this hot and how serious
I guess is he well allegation yeah yeah
I'm sure China's taking them pretty
seriously this is what we know us
officials speaking to us on condition of
anonymity say that Chinese hackers they
allege that they were indeed from China
believed to be linked to the Chinese
government got into the computers of the
US Office of Personnel Management why is
that important well they have the
personal records of almost all the US
government employees and retired
employees they allegedly stole records
of as many as four million current and
former employees the breach was detected
in April really all the way back in
April yeah two months ago okay well uh
what would what would the authorities or
people in China want with this
information well that's what that's a
good question actually but security
experts are saying that these are
healthcare records personal records
marital status all kinds of stuff that
potentially could be used you know in
case they wanted to do bribery blackmail
entrapment this is what security and
espionage experts say this kind of
information is used also there was a lot
of information about the details of job
interviews for US government jobs that
have security clearance that kind of
information what kind of questions they
ask what kind of clearance they got that
kind of information could be used by
foreign governments tim is okay
allegation is pretty serious pointed the
finger China now these attacks n all
come from China by a long searched
imagine no I mean Russia has been
fingerprinted on a number of attacks
according to US officials into the White
House into the Pentagon actually we have
the Pentagon's top advisor on
cybersecurity saying hackers from more
than 100 foreign intelligent Ferb's
probe the Pentagon computer networks
alone every day millions of times ping
ping ping ping ping see when they can
get in and that's what thieves do they
knock on all the doors or wiggle the
latula Betsy with and I'm sure that
Washington itself is not immune to also
looking and trying to find you think
what's going on elsewhere yeah
allegedly